from father greg how about that i'm a
catholic priest
riding you from the frozen land to the
north known as canada
which i lovingly call america's hat
recently our premiere declared that
churches are only allowed 30 people
regardless of size while businesses are
allowed 50
capacity moreover the restriction on
churches is effective immediately
whereas the restrictions on businesses
don't come into effect till december
25th
here is my question is it time we
reconsider this whole selling of
indulgences thing
perhaps we gave it up too quickly johann
tetzel
had some problems with mismanagement but
the underlying business model strikes me
as sound
moreover i've already spoken to several
of my protestant friends
who are warm to the idea if it means
they could go to church
wouldn't that be the perfect ending to
2020 catholics and protestants coming
together around indulgences
let me know what you think in christ
father greg an excellent point you
raised father
it had not occurred to me but it's an
excellent point frankly
i don't really have much of an issue
with the sale of indulgences generally i
think this is you know as
i suspect you know as well this is a
very misrepresented
topic and a very very exaggerated topic
and
i don't think that uh i think indulge
indulgences obviously
or still exist as they should and i i
think giving alms is a very good thing
and i think those things go well
together
uh but beyond that even just from a
purely political standpoint
it would be delightful it would be
it would be one of the wonderful joyous
turns of providence
if the sale of indulgences could bring
the catholic and protestant
protestants back together because in our
day and age
the the secular religion that we all
have the secular religion of liberalism
understands that only commerce is uh
the protected activity that's the
liturgy that we have to protect
all these silly things like going to
church you know or going to synagogue
that that's crazy you don't need to do
any of that you just got to go buy more
stuff well okay
two can play at that game very very wise
idea of other great
[Music]
[Music]